madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition après la disparition de l'avion
de john kennedy
il n'y aurait plus d'espoir de retrouver
des survivants en mer les recherches
néanmoins se poursuivre
l'amérique pleure l'une des figures de
la dynastie kennedy les chaînes de
télévision suivent en direct l'événement
le fils du président assassiné qui avait
épousé carolyn bessette jeune fille sage
de la bonne société new yorkaise
symbolisait la réussite et la séduction
dans ce journal reportage documents et
intervention en direct de nos envoyés
spéciaux
la parade nautique de l'armada qui a
quitté le port de rouen plus d'un
million de personnes sur les berges de
la seine pour assister à ce spectacle
maritime
et puis du tennis la victoire de cédric
pioline qui a battu que ça vaut corten
il donne à la france la qualification
pour la demi-finale de la coupe davis
même si la mairie que redoute d'annoncer
officiellement la disparition de john
kennedy il ne reste pratiquement aucune
chance de retrouver vivant le fils du
président assassiné ainsi que son épouse
car une bessette et sa soeur la
température de l'océan est trop froide
pour imaginer qu'ils aient pu survivre
selon des spécialistes pour autant les
recherches se poursuivent autour de
l'île de martha's vineyard à la
recherche de l'épave
olivier caroff officiellement ce sont
toujours des survivants que recherchent
les secouristes mais cela fait trente
six heures maintenant que l'avion de
john kennedy junior s'est abîmé en mer
le fils du président assassiné était aux
commandes à bord sa femme et sa belle
soeur
même s'ils ont survécu au crash il y a
peu de chances qu'il puisse tenir aussi
longtemps dans les eaux froides de
l'atlantique
d'habitude on peut survivre une douzaine
d'heures admet le responsable des
recherches mais il s'empresse d'ajouter
que ce n'est qu'une moyenne statistique
les patrouilles continue donc avions
spécialisés des garde-côtes navire
océanographique équipé de sonars
c'est une zone de trois mille kilomètres
carrés qu'il faut explorer à la
recherche de l'épave de cet appareil un
piper saratoga que john kennedy junior
avait acheté d'occasion il ya quelques
mois pour remplacer ce premier avion
que s'est-il passé pendant le vol les
écrans radars ont noté une chute de 400
mètres en quelques secondes et c'est
tout il n'y a même pas eu d'appel de
détresse sur l'île de martha's vineyard
là où john kennedy junior aurait dû
atterrir vendredi soir la police
sillonnent les plages à la recherche de
débris déposée par l'océan une valise et
quelques pièces ont été retrouvées hier
et ce matin les recherches pourrait
s'étendre désormais à une petite île
toute proche
un îlot désert utilisé pour les tirs
d'entraînement de la marine américaine
dans la résidence d'été des kennedy là
où devait se dérouler la cérémonie de
mariage de l'un des leurs le clan une
nouvelle fois frappée par la tragédie
fait bloc
le recueillement pour ces quelques 80
membres de la famille kennedy soudée
unie par l'émotion sur place notre
correspondant dominique derda edouard
terrain dès lors d'autres navires sont
partis en renfort la nuit ne fut
porteuse d'aucune heureuse nouvelle
arrêt hyannis port où l'on devait
célébrer hier le plus chic le plus
mondain des mariages il fallait ce matin
avoir la foi bien arrimé pour résister
encore contre vents et marées à l'
angoisse et surtout à la résignation
échantillons main c'est vrai dit cette
femme mais moi j'ai toujours espoir
il faut continuer à trier ce n'est pas
la première fois loin de là que les
kennedy font la une de la presse dans ce
petit village comme dans toute
l'amérique les éditions spéciales
partent en quelques heures
et chacun évidemment de s'interroger sur
cet acharnement du destin c'est
peut-être leur richesse qui les a tué 17
émigrés russes pourquoi ne sont ils pas
venus en autobus ou en voiture à ce
mariage
pourquoi fallait-il absolument qu'ils y
viennent en avion c'est du monde entier
qu'ils sont venus et nous sur leurs
traces depuis plus de 24 heures près à
tout instant à prendre l'antenne devant
la propriété familiale
ils guettent un mouvement un signe un
cri de joie ou de détresse
la fin d'une histoire qui à mesure que
le temps passe et criera c'est bien
probable en lettres de deuil
il n'y a guère au pied de son phare que
sam le peintre pour constellé de
couleurs la grisaille uniforme d'un
paysage écrasée de soleil autant que le
tristesse si nous l'avons perdu dit-il
ce serait une grande perte mais nous
nous souviendrons de lui comme nous nous
souvenons de lady diana
toujours pour nous ils iront ensemble
sur ces plages ou john john fit ses
premiers châteaux de sable pour tous qui
depuis la mort de son père le couvert du
regard il était l'enfant roi le prince
charmant de l'amérique
toutes les chaînes de télévision aux
états unis ont modifié leur programme et
suivent en direct l'évolution des
recherches les journaux du dimanche ont
fait leur une sur la tragédie retraçant
le parcours de celui qui fait partie
intégrante de l'histoire américaine
depuis ce jour de novembre 63 à dallas
spontanément des passants déposent des
fleurs devant la résidence de john
kennedy à new york et d'autres se
recueillent au cimetière d'arlington
là où et intérêts le président assassiné
patrick fandio
en se réveillant ce matin l'amérique
n'était pas en deuil même si certains
signes montrent qu'elles s'y prépare
déjà la bannière étoilée 9 l'autre qu'à
moitié sur le capitole à washington
le drapeau n'est pas encore en berne on
attend insupportable attente cruel
incertitude pour ces américains qui
viennent déposer au pied de l'immeuble
où habite john john et caroline quelques
fleurs quelques bougies un petit mode
angoisse ou êtes-vous donc john s'il
vous plaît rentrez vite à la maison je
reçois un manque un manque de quelqu'un
comme lorsque vous regardez la
télévision
on ne connaît pas l'homme mais on se
souvient d'un petit enfant et de son
salut militaire
et quand vous le voyez à l'écran vous
vous dites lui c'est un personnage où il
vient ce qui va faire où il va vous
espérez toujours le meilleur pour lui
alors par heure les médias américains
alimente évidemment ce mélodrame
nationale tirage supplémentaire édition
spéciale ils s'y sont tous mis de la
presse à sensation qui promet en une
encore des larmes au très sérieux et
très influent quotidien qui rivalise des
analyses pour savoir ce qu'ont bien pu
faire les kennedy pour mériter
l'acharnement d'un destin si tragique
même l'austère herald tribune échappe à
l'émotion ambiante
et pour cause l'histoire des kennedy
pour les américains ne ressemble
vraiment à rien de comparable
c'est un peu une saga une famille qui a
traversé vraiment tous depuis des
décennies tous les drames humains qui
sont tout le monde dans le monde entier
les gens peuvent prouver quelque chose
en commun avec cette famille c'est un
peu comme la famille royale britannique
ou même je dirais ce sont des gens que
tu vrai que ce n'est pas de la loyauté
ont commencé une famille d'immigrants
l'amérique n'est pourtant pas une
monarchie mais elle s'inquiète jusqu'au
plus haut sommet de l'état pour le
prince héritier de ceux qui ici font
figure de famille royale je souhaite
commencer avec un moment de prière pour
john kennedy junior pour sa femme
caroline et sa soeur lorraine qui nous
reviennent sains et saufs et bientôt la
prière et le recueillement il ne reste
peut-être plus que ça à faire pour ceux
qui se retrouvent sur la tombe du
président assassiné le père de john au
cimetière militaire d'arlington
ou alors à l'office religieux célébré
tout à l'heure à la cathédrale saint
patrick de new york john kennedy
représentait pour l'amérique la
génération positive de la dynastie un
symbole fait à la fois de réussite de
séduction et d'une joie de vivre enfin
retrouver l'enfant chéri des amériques à
protéger de la presse durant son enfance
par sa mère avait su se débarrasser du
poids de la fatalité du moins le croyait
tant michel film de son enfance et de
son adolescence il reste peu d'image
celle d'un petit bonhomme à côté de son
père sur un tarmac d'aéroport et celle
ci qui a fait le tour du monde un enfant
de trois ans faisant le salut militaire
devant la dépouille mortelle de son papa
john john kennedy a grandi sous l'oeil
de sa mère loin des paparazzi
on dit parfois de lui que dans la
famille kennedy il est le plus normal de
tous deux fait john john et en
dilettante
tour à tour il fait un peu de théâtre et
joue à deux reprises à son examen
d'avocats puis devient assistant du
procureur de manhattan
prétentieux en a en fait son problème
son seul problème dans la vie c'était de
gérer son capital qui était son en 1995
il résout ce problème
john john kennedy lance un magazine
politique grand public son nom djordje
du nom de george washington fondateurs
des états unis john roos bac que georges
lève le rideau sur la politique et nous
montre les hommes et les femmes sur la
scène publique
un journal à son image il y avait un
petit côté clin d'oeil je voulais parce
que explique ce avec dans la politique
le sublime côtoie le ridicule et je
crois qu'il voulait souligner sur de
dualité la presse après le mariage de
john john kennedy en recevant cette
unique photo il s'est uni en 1996 dans
le plus grand secret devant quelques
dizaines d'invités seulement avec
carolyn bessette jeune fille de bonne
famille 28 ans elle est la fille d'un
médecin de new york travaille chez
calvin klein où elle est responsable de
la communication à l'école elle fut
désigné archétype de la beauté de lui on
disait qu'il était l'homme le plus sexy
du monde
il faisait rêver des milliers de gens
avec la disparition de celui qu'on
représentait comme le prince héritier de
l'amérique
revenons à présent sur l'histoire de la
famille kennedy une histoire émaillée de
tragédie de destins brisés
bob kennedy avait lui même déclaré un
jour il y a quelqu'un là haut qui ne
nous aiment pas il est vrai que le sort
s'est acharné trop souvent philippe
rochot il représente l image du bonheur
et de la réussite quand jacky et john
fitzgerald kennedy ont fêté leur
victoire aux présidentielles de 60
il pensait bien que les drames qui
s'était déjà abattues sur la famille ne
se reproduirait pas joseph kennedy
s'était tué en 44 dans un accident
d'avion à l'âge de 29 ans et quatre ans
plus tard sa soeur catherine avait aussi
trouvé la mort dans la chute de son
appareil en france l' assassinat à
dallas de john fitzgerald kennedy allait
montrer au monde que la malédiction
s'abattait sur cette famille à tel point
que le petit john aujourd'hui disparus a
dit un jour à sa mère il ya au ciel
quelqu'un qui nous en veut l'assassinât
de son frère robert en pleine campagne
présidentielle à los angeles allait lui
donner raison
c'était en 68 et bob quelques minutes
après son discours tombait comme son
frère sous les balles de ses assassins
au scanner dit la mère de ses neuf
enfants kennedy qui dit on leur donne à
cette envergure qui a fait leur gloire
révéla aussi qu'elle perdit un enfant un
mois après sa naissance
mais avant sa mort 95 elle se consola de
ces drames
en voyant qu'elle avait trente petits
enfants et 41 arrière petits enfants
car ses fils n'ont pas seulement apporté
la tragédie dans la famille mais aussi
la honte comme ted kennedy en 69
sa compagne est morte noyée au cours
d'un mystérieux accident de voiture le
sénateur ted kennedy a dû formuler
publiquement des xxii excuse pour ne pas
salir la famille ted kennedy junior lui
amputer de la jambe gauche à la suite
d'un cancer
forçat de son côté l'admiration des
américains alors que david kennedy fils
de robert allait succomber d'une
overdose de drogue en 84 le dernier
drame
ce fut la mort de michael kennedy autre
fils de robert kennedy mort dans un
accident de ski dans le colorado il y a
deux ans john kennedy junior était venu
saluer sa mémoire
ignorant qu'il serait le prochain
kennedy à mourir lui aussi de façon
tragique ou commandes de son avion
rejoignant maintenant directeur des
états unis à yanis porte dominique derda
d'abord peut-être quelques précisions
concernant les circonstances de
l'accident de l'avion piloté par john
kennedy
apparemment plusieurs témoignages
évoquent eu l'imprudence ou plutôt le
manque d'expérience
oui on peut dire on est encore c'est un
peu difficile de l'affirmer maintenant
parce que l'anc est évidemment ne fait
que commencer
john fitzgerald kennedy junior ne donne
avait son brevet de pilote que dame
depuis un peu plus d'un an simplement là
dans le domaine dans lequel il était
inexpérimenté s'était sans doute
l'utilisent l'utilisation de cet
appareil un appareil qu'il s'était
offert il n'y a pas très longtemps
ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il ne
disposait pas de sa qualification pour
piloter aux instruments les conditions
météo
avant-hier soir dans la nuit les
conditions météos apparemment était
assez mauvaise il y avait beaucoup de
brume il faisait nuit et on sait très
bien qu'il est beaucoup plus difficile
de se diriger à vue quand il fait nuit
dans la brûle
surtout si l'on ne sait pas assez
investi on ne sait pas se servir de ces
secondes
alors même si rien est officiel selon
quel calendrier les autorités vont elles
annoncé la fin des recherches et est sur
place se prépare-t-on déjà aux obsèques
écoutez j'aurais envie de dire que
plutôt que de l'annoncer la fin dès la
fin des recherches
on en est plutôt à la ici et aujourd'hui
a annoncé une intensification de ses
recherches simplement sur un périmètre
beaucoup plus réduit que le périmètre de
départ qui était extrêmement vaste d une
centaine de kilomètres carrés en mer au
large de vie si les moyens vont être
renforcées on utilise le d'ores et déjà
un navire qui était qui est équipé d'un
sonar qui permet de voir si des débris
chanteuse songe fait le sol de la mer
qui est pas très profond à cet endroit
là on a utilisé des systèmes de vision
nocturne de détection de chaleur afin de
voir si par hasard décor flotteraient
sur la mer en tout état de cause tant
qu'on n'aura pas d'éléments plus précis
plus concret il est difficile d'imaginer
que l'on que l'on arrête cette enquête
ils savaient ici on parle encore
d'opérations de secours et pas
simplement de rapatriement de débris
c'est la raison sans doute pour laquelle
la famille kennedy ne s'est pas encore
exprimé tant que les recherches de
secours ne sont pas encore terminée
officiellement
merci dominique derda pour ces
précisions voici ce que l'on pouvait
dire sur la disparition de john kennedy
nous y reviendrons toute fin de journal
pour un dernier point dans l'actualité
au kosovo la découverte d'un nouveau
site où auraient été massacrées 26
personnes
il s'agit de la zone nord sous
commandement français les corps des
victimes étaient dispersés autour d'un
village près du ce bric à cette personne
porteraient des traces de balles dans la
tête et puis presque comme chaque jour
maintenant une nouvelle manifestation de
l'opposition réclamant le départ du
leader serbe 15000 personnes emmenées
par vue grâce vite se sont réunis hier à
une centaine de kilomètres au sud de
belgrade
jérôme benest vuk draskovic renoue avec
l'opposition
c'est son premier meeting depuis que
milosevic le limogeage en avril dernier
pendant les frappes de l'otan
les manifestations contre le président
serbe se succèdent dans les villes de
province
l'opposition est à la recherche d'une
figure charismatique
tout le monde doit se réunir dans
l'opposition sans quoi il n'y aura pas
de changement de notre serbie moribonde
après béthune a connu quelqu'un n'est
pas capable d'être un bon dirigeant
il doit partir comme ça se passe dans
les pays du monde civilisé kragujevac
est une ville sinistrée par la guerre
une ville de chômeurs après les
bombardements des usines automobiles
axslav à une ville envahie par des
milliers de réfugiés serbes du kosovo si
les américains permettent que le kosovo
devienne un pays s'en servent alors
pourquoi pas demain des etats-unis sans
américain grâce kovic tient à se
démarquer de ceux qui veulent renverser
milosevic
il prône des élections les supporteurs
de milosevic
je ne veux pas leur offrir la prison la
vengeance la souffrance je ne suis pas
un homme de vengeance je suis un homme
de réconciliation
chacun prend ses marques en yougoslavie
pour un été de toutes les oppositions
qui s'annonce particulièrement chaud
dans moins de 48 heures et pour marquer
le jour anniversaire du premier pas de
l'homme sur la lune le lancement de la
navette columbia à cap canaveral pour la
première fois c'est une femme qui
dirigera l'équipage composé de cinq
astronautes dont le français michel
tonini la première femme commandant de
bord s'appelle hélène caudines
jean-claude allanic et philippe lui dit
leur rencontre et leur point commun ils
sont tous les deux pilotes de chasse et
astronaute
le français michel perin a volé dans
mire avec les rues 192 eileen collins
lieutenant colonel de l'us air force et
déjà les deux fois dans l'espace
cette fois ci elle sera commandant de
bord de la navette une première pour une
femme aux états unis ait fana
j'essaye de ne pas penser au fait que je
suis la première femme commandant de
bord l'important c'est le travail que
j'ai à faire et 4 et après vol un
commandant de bord qui a dirigé
l'entraînement de son équipage à houston
avec le sourire mais une bonne faire
consciente que les hommes de la nasa ne
lui ferait pas forcément de cadeaux j'ai
pris avec sa construction était un peu
les heat en jeu
demander un petit peu ce qui allait se
passer et en fait des rapports c'est un
livre c'est un but très très bien avec
aline parce que elle est très facile
d'être est rigoureuse elle ne fasse
aucun détail ce type sont super on a
travaillé payant de longues journées on
est presque devenu une famille ça me
fait travailler le week-end et au fur et
à mesure qu'on se rapproche du décollage
on travaille encore plus une famille qui
s'est entraîné dix heures par jour
pendant plusieurs mois parfois au fond
de cette piscine géante par exemple pour
s'exercer à une sortie dans l'espace en
ce cas fin et quand il fallait
superviser une chose de plus près le
commandant de bord n'a jamais hésité à
se jeter à l'eau en dehors du travail à
lynn collins partage sa vie avec un mari
pilote calling et elle consacre ses
loisirs à sa petite fille
ma fille a presque trois ans elle ne
comprend pas exactement ce que je fais
mais elle sait que c'est très
particulier et que c'est un amant va
monter dans une fusée salle excite
beaucoup d'alcool à une petite fille à
qui sa maman aura beaucoup de choses à
raconter
quand elle redescendra des étoiles
l'actualité en france ce matin paris
jour anniversaire de la rafle du vel
d'hiv elisabeth guigou a salué la
mémoire des victimes de ces crimes
imprescriptibles lors de la
commémoration de cette rave qui s'est
déroulé à quelques mètres de l'ancien
vélodrome d'hiver le 16 juillet 42 et le
lendemain quatre mille cinq cents
policiers français avaient arrêtés à
leur domicile plus de 13000 juifs eux
rassemblés dans l'ancien vélodrome avant
d'être déportés le garde des sceaux a
souligné son désir de regarder la vérité
en face
le magistral défilé nautique de l'armada
qui donc quitté ce matin le port de roi
pour descendre la scène une vingtaine de
grands voiliers des deux bâtiments de
guerre salué sur les rives par de très
nombreux spectateurs
on parlait d'un à deux millions de
personnes le long des berges thierry
kurt et lewis-roberts à la parade plus
de quinze grand trois-mâts puis le 30
navires
la fête n'a véritablement pris fin que
lorsqu'ils ont franchi le pont de
normandie ce soir à chaque passage de
village les 70 cadet de doigté moque ont
assuré le spectacle à claudie dans
chaque traversée de village par une
foule impossible à des nombreux les plus
audacieux évoque plus de 3 millions de
personnes sur les berges de la seine 120
kilomètres de rouen waouh pour cette
troisième édition des habitués avaient
tout prévu
la bière sur les navires ravis de
l'accueil les marins ne sont pas
spécialement pressé de reprendre du car
au delà sur le produit brême allemand
salsa en solo sous les voiles du simon
bolivar les grand trois mâts du bout du
monde se confondent de plus en plus avec
le décor normand devant le succès 8
millions de spectateurs estimés au total
les organisateurs ont décidé que la
prochaine armada aura lieu dans quatre
ans au lieu de cinq
sur les quais ce matin le coeur était
serré
on les reverra q c'est à dire ah ils
s'en vont et puis à l'âge à bouleverser
théorie mais j'peux pas non si la passe
trop vite fait bien
on s'attache à quoi s'attache acquis aux
marins au bâton à l'ambiance ou si vous
souhaitez qu'est ce que vous espérez
maintenant mais qui reviennent
certains certaines couronne prochaine
escale aux abois saint malo car ces
grandes cathédrales de voile ne viennent
pas si souvent alors elles prennent leur
temps avant de retraverser l'atlantique
l'actualité sportive avec la victoire de
cédric pioline qui a battu gustavo
kuerten qualifiant ainsi la france pour
les demi-finales de la coupe davis à pau
christelle bertrand marie richard en
coupe davis
une victoire ça s'arrose toujours par
une douche conserver que l'équipe avait
de bons joueurs on s'aperçoit aussi que
ce sont de bons danseurs en quelques
minutes
cédric pioline a changé de bouteilles
sur le court il fallait avoir les idées
claires
celle de cuir ten sont plus embrouillée
le brésilien a subi sans pouvoir réagir
pioline seul maître du court à tout de
suite sorti le grand jeu
kuerten a bien essayé d'enrayer le
métronome français mais pioline a stoppé
net toutes les ambitions brésiliennes et
pour être tout à fait un battable cédric
pioline a servi et volleye sans fausse
note
au bout de deux sets perdus 6 3 6 4
curtain a bien senti que souffler sur le
court un petit air de coupe du monde
et un et deux et trois manches à zéro
pour pioline comme au football les
joueurs se sont échangé les maillots
cédric pioline a fait une partie solide
en profitant des faiblesses de kertel on
a débuté un palier
à partir de là
allez c'est beaucoup
les français sont en demi finale de
coupe davis le capitaine est fier de ses
tuniques bleues 3 c'est la fête ce
week-end c'est que les joueurs ont joué
tous les quatre un très grand tennis
dans votre capitaine suis vraiment
comblé aujourd'hui
score final 3 2 sébastien grosjean s'est
incliné face à midi génie du 24 au 26
septembre
la france va jouer contre la belgique
pour une place en finale le tour de
france avec la 14e étape au pied des
pyrénées l'américain lance amstrong
conserve le maillot jaune c'est le russe
konyshev qui a remporté l'épreuve
nathanaël de rincquesen un fil des
langues
jour après jour étape après étape lance
armstrong se complaît dans son maillot
jaune
bien à l'abri derrière ses coéquipiers
l'américain géré son avance voulait dans
le peloton c'est très utile surtout dans
une étape comme aujourd'hui lorsqu'il
s'agit de se protéger de la pluie
peu après le départ de castres
cette chute permet à deux hommes de
s'échapper konyshev et durant ils sont
rejoints par quatre autres coureurs au
62e kilomètre l'avancent du potier
groupe va dépasser les 15 minutes durant
tente bien de partir seul pour offrir à
la france sa première victoire sur le
tour
en vain il se laisse même surprendre par
konyshev et farzine à 5 km de saint
gaudens
dimitri konyshev le russe s'impose au
sprint
durand termine 5e après 14 étapes les
français sont toujours à la recherche
d'une première victoire
lance armstrong lui savoure déjà la
journée de repos demain à saint gaudens
bien utile avant d'affronter les
pyrénées
pour la défense de la langue bretonne
cette lettre ouverte à jacques chirac
distribués aux participants de cette
cérémonie dans le finistère qui
réunissait une centaine de druide du
pays de galles et des cornouailles
ils se sont retrouvés lors d'une
cérémonie très rituel pour célébrer le
centenaire de leur fraternité réclama
sans vraiment châtelard n'ont vraiment
rien ne manque ni le son de la bombarde
à la rosée du matin
ni le grand druide qui ressemble
forcément un druide
non décidément pour leur centenaire ses
droïdes du gorsedd bretons n'ont rien
oublié de leur folklore à même les paies
vendus dont les moitiés s'unissent comme
subi ces peuples celtes à même les
cousins a couru nombreux du pays de
galles et de toute la cornouaille
je suis le pack des cornouailles en être
druides et celtes
certes mais de quoi s'agit-il au juste
revêtir une selle bleues ou blanches
saurait-il du dernier chic avant l'an
2000 et surtout à quoi ça sert
voici philly 39 ans après plusieurs
années d'apprentissage de la langue
bretonne
c'est aujourd'hui qu'il prend le titre
de druides et le voici dans son champ
car dans le civil ce droid et
agriculteurs vous n'étiez pas breton
vous dites moi moi au départ
manon marché noir moselle et gerbe et
minute breton de coeur
philippe et son épouse ont l'agriculture
pour vocation tardive
ils viennent de s'installer agriculture
biologique tendance new age avec menhir
au fond du champ et drapeaux bretons
planté dans chaque phrase de voir
comment cette culture n'est pas reconnu
par ba l'état français parce que bon
c'est bien ce qui se passe pour la
bretagne
elle est occupée par l'état français
cette culture et les nier
déjà dans sa langue pour moi ensuite
dans tout ce qui fait sa richesse est
heureux de voir ça j'ai ressenti comme
une injustice aussi les c'est peut-être
pour ça que j'ai commencé à militer à
m'engager quoi toute façon on
un peu tout c'est une période où on
cherche et des racines alors là les
racines en bretagne oui c'est c'est la
tradition celtique donc aussi le
tourisme
pour autant ce renouveau celtique n'est
pas le terreau d'un nationalisme breton
qui demeure plus que marginal non ce
retour en force du druidisme illustre
plutôt un besoin que la religion combler
jadis l'immense goût des hommes pour le
sacré deuxième jour des défilés de la
haute couture avec sur le podium les
créations de jean paul gaultier qui
cette année fait partie du sérail des
grands couturiers pour sa part givenchy
a fait son cinéma salle et dans les
studios de boulogne billancourt
reportage me colle corps d'une angloys
bernard connard
coup de théâtre chez givenchy les
mannequins sont statiques et les visages
en plexiglas alexander mcqueen at il
décidé de créer une mode musée que l'on
regarderait comme un tableau dans une
galerie
il précise qu'il s'est inspiré de cette
peinture de paul delaroche sur
l'exécution de lady jane grey petite
pièce dans huit
parce qu'il est dit il un utopique
romantique
ce que confirme ses modèles plus fait
pour être admiré que pour être portées
les clients devront elles s'identifier à
ces spectres sans vie ni sensualité le
pari risqué
même si le talent est évident et
brillant
mais alexander mcqueen a déjà prouvé
qu'il était un provocateur doublé d'un
magicien
jean paul gaultier haute couture des
pieds à la tête structure infaillible
pour un bustier miracle et de la
fourrure de toutes les couleurs du
renard en vaste jupe en bordure ou en
écharpe et même de l'hermine en col
vertige et poignets est basé ce créateur
affectionne les plumes qu'elle soit
d'autruche de pintade qu'ils mélangent à
des coquillages pour un oiseau barre il
utilise aussi la peau de crocodile le
cuir métallisé ou les pâtes d'autres
champions talons aiguilles
il aime toujours les découpes inédite et
les gadgets comme ses gants longs
intégrant un agenda ou un portable
le plastique s'allie aux dentelles et
broderies en imperméable ou en robe de
mariée de velours de soie
jean paul gaultier a beau être consacré
en haute couture il ne se prend pas au
sérieux et c'est tant mieux
ces musiques de films sont célèbres il a
composé les grands thèmes d'arizona
dream d'underground ou du temps des
gitans des murs costa rica cette fois ci
le compositeur goran bregovic et son
orchestre des mariages et des
enterrements se produit arles le
tempérament volcanique de l'artiste
rencontre avec karine comazzi ait besoin
de tunis sur les ruines du théâtre
antique d'arles une rafale de
kalachnikov
une petite chanson dédiée aux soldats
des balkans est alors jouer les âmes
chagrines crieront à la naissance c'est
mal connaître goran bregovic essafri
culotte fanfare des mariages et les
enterrements tôt
né d'un père croate et d'une mère serbe
marienne musulmane ce grand enfant
passage brandit le métissage comme son
pouce sur drapeau sonné dans un pays
frankenstein
il voit cela vie c'est un pays plus
inquiétant dans tous le sens
c'est fait des morceaux qui qui qui
colle pas très bien et c'est la même
chose dans tous le sens dans la musique
aussi on est entouré par le grand
musique du sud italien grec où le gars
on voit ce que je fais c'est ce qu'il
sait très kitsch jeudi quitte jeudi à
une besoin humaines de sentir chaleur
les mots ce que je fais c'est sa tête
avec son reggae planant et ses chants
gitans bregovic a traversé les
frontières comme un poisson volant
pourtant c'est à belgrade qu'il revient
chaque fois pour composer un peu
inconfortable mais tu fais pas changer
ce destin c'est comme le saumon tu as
c'est beaucoup plus facile d'être
sardines nager dans la grande salle
confortable jolie cité ni commencement
il faut aller dans le petit flux mois
signer là bas j'ai partenaires
serbe bulgare gitans sur scène les
balkans ne connaissent ni les frontières
ni la guerre
le festival des francofolies de la
rochelle se termine ce soir une soirée
entièrement consacrée europe
cette manifestation qui avait du mal à
trouver un second souffle semble cette
année renouer avec le succès une
programmation plus variée jouant sur
tous les registres avec notamment une
place se fait à la musique de l'amérique
latine éric perrin christophe génial
kong à tim bale et setubal la rochelle
et branché salsa lancer dans le rap new
yorkais pur et dur que mangou a baigné
durant toute son enfance passée dans le
bronze il aura fallu un déménagement en
floride et la roulette avec des
pointures de la musique latino pour que
naisse la salsa assaisonner au hip hop
une jeunesse monsieur les d'origine
dominicaine il a le sang latin le sang
chaud comme moi je suis cubain un ou
deux on peut faire des choses qui vont
vous rendre complètement fou
il
on
oui
car outre son poids pour
non
la musique latine et joyeuse mais on ne
raconte pas toujours des histoires à
l'eau de rose
il ya des chansons qui traitent et c'est
d'ailleurs un point commun avec le rav
de problèmes sociaux très préoccupant
mais cette musique a tellement de
vibrations que souvent vous font oublier
les paroles le groupe le rythme ils sont
les avec à salvador de bahia la ville la
plus africaine du brésil carlinhos brown
incarne plus que quiconque cette énergie
du métissage mystique il ne monte jamais
sur scène avant cette séance de contes
d'emblée mélange de christianisme et de
vaudou activistes politiques
il a créé une école de musique dans son
bidonville aventure musicale hors pair
le personnage et disons le aussi
excentrique enthousiasmant
preuve est faite que loin des clichés
cha cha cha pour thé dansant la musique
latine ne cesse d'évoluer tout en
gardant ses racines fait de générosité
au cou avant de refermer ce journal le
revenant sur la disparition de john
kennedy bill clinton devrait faire une
déclaration d'ici une heure c'est ce
qu'on apprend à l'instant
apparemment le président n'aurait pas de
nouvelles informations mais ils
souhaitent de partager ses réflexions
avec les américains reste que ce soir il
n'y aurait pratiquement aucune chance de
retrouver vivant le fils du président
assassiné le point philippe rochot cet
hercule c 130 est spécialisé dans les
recherches ainsi que ce navire équipé
d'un sonar mais depuis l'aube ils n'ont
repéré aucun corps à 15 km au large des
côtes du massachusetts
là où l'appareil de john kennedy junior
s'est abîmé avec à bord son épouse
caroline et lorraine sa soeur l'eau est
à 20 degrés et aucun être humain ne peut
tenir plus de quelques heures
c'est ce qui fait dire aux autorités
américaines que john kennedy junior et
les siens n'ont pas survécu
mais personne n'ose officiellement
l'annoncé car on a retrouvé jusque là
qu'une valise portant le nom de sa belle
soeur et un appui tête de l'avion
pourtant les conditions météo sont
bonnes meilleur en tout cas que lorsque
john kennedy junior a pris les commandes
de son appareil pour se rendre à hyannis
port à mesure que l'on s'enfonce dans le
temps l'émotion grandit aux états unis
dans le camp kennedy là où l'internaute
john john et sa femme
l'heure est au recueillement alors que
dehors on estime que 3000 journalistes
attendent des nouvelles de celui que
l'on appelait l'enfant chéri de
l'amérique ses fans cette édition je
vous remercie de l'avoir suivi dans un
instant la météo présentée par patrice
drevet 20h50 votre film le ruffian avec
lino ventura à 00h10 le journal de la
nuit sera présentée par laurence
ostolaza demain 20h vous retrouverez
benoît duquesne excellente des vacances
à ceux qui ont la chance d'en prendre
merci de votre attention
bonne fin de soirée sur france 2